let me ask you this
sure your new back attacks instructional
first of all awesome yeah uh second of
all
you dropped you drop a lot of
fascinating insights in there but
you quote galileo out of all people in
saying that you can't teach a man
anything
you can only help him find it within
himself
so we talked about how to start in jiu
jitsu
what about if we zoom out even more and
how do you learn how to learn
how do you optimize the learning process
i
i don't know the answer to that but i
can tell you what i like to do and i
would say like
i can't step one i don't i'm not maybe
this is a little bit easier for me
because
you know i've i've never had a ton of
friends honestly i've you know i've got
my close friends and people that i know
but i
never had tons and tons of people so i
spent a lot of time you know thinking
and anyway uh yeah i can't
i can't control you i can't control
anybody else i
you know i uh um
all i can i want to take my it's a
marcus aurelius thing it's like you know
i guess the trick to life is figuring
out what's in our control and what's not
and focusing on things that are in our
control i guess
and uh so step one is figuring out both
internally and then also
out in in the world as it pertains to
jitsu what is actually in my control and
what it's not like passing someone's
guard is not in your control people
think it is it ain't
if i can't just do an activity and be
unchecked
then it ain't in my control entirely
i can always breathe i can always um
you know be calm i can always no matter
whether i'm concerned
or not concerned whatever you want to
call it nerves you know i can
step forward across the line and say i
will i will face the challenge ahead
that is all entirely no one can stop me
from doing that that's entirely my
control and that's why
i know that every single time that i
walk into the ring i'll walk in and out
of there with my head of high
because there's i will fight with
everything that i have
i can't promise that i'll win i would
say i take that same
first principles you mentioned the last
time we talked you know with
elon and the importance of that and
going what are the first principles and
i guess to come back a lot of times in
my opinion things that people think are
the basics are not the basics
you can't learn if you think you're
reasoning for first principles but
you're actually like level six
you're actually like layers up you're
making so many there's so many baked in
assumptions to what's going on that
you're going to struggle to understand
why anything is actually happening
internally externally you name
it so i guess what i would start when it
comes to learning is
first principles and trying to
understand what's going on but then also
simple things first i can control my
posture
i can control my breathing no one can
stop me from doing that i can control
where i place my frames i can control
where i place my limbs
i can move my feet i can develop the
ability to do these things better of
course and i do that through practice
through drilling through watching people
i've been incredibly
fortunate in my time in martial arts to
train with many of my heroes to train
with many of the people
that i looked at and i was like that guy
is amazing i want to train with this
person like
stephen thompson kenny florian george st
pierre raymond daniels ferraza hobby
you know i mean like bruno farzado
marcelo garcia you know all of these
guys
that are just unbelievable and i go well
they're moving in a way that's different
how do i do that well sometimes you can
ask them and they can tell you directly
other times people
part of the genius of what they do is
that it's intuitive and maybe they don't
think and understand and see the world
the same way that i do that was
something that i experienced with
marcelo
um he's amazing but in in a different
way
than his it just we see things
fundamentally different we experience
the world differently it seems to me
that we do
um and again that that taught me a
really important lesson because i was
wanting when i trained there to have
someone go hey ryan do this this this
and this and that's how it works and i'm
like all right because that's how i
understood martial arts at the time
um i wasn't ready to have someone tell
me like hey
um it feels a little bit like this and i
just kind of do it
which is kind of what marcelo would do
at the time as he was less experienced
as a teacher
but that is what he was doing i was
completely
i couldn't separate in my mind
performance
and understanding i thought that if i
understand i could do it and i would
also want to i would also struggle
sometimes to
wonder why i couldn't execute things
that i thought i understood
and why guys like marcelo were just so
elemental i mean in like that like
lightning wind like that type of thing
like it's just so in touch with
what they wanted with with their
capabilities they could summon their
powers at will
i couldn't always do that and i guess
so recognizing that there was more than
one way to the top of the mountain and
also i had a lot of science but i didn't
have a lot of art or i had some science
i should say but i didn't have a lot of
art
meeting people like marcelo taught me
and then josh wadeskin actually
brilliant guy uh chess champion um
former owner maybe owner of marcellus
academy really great friend i think he
has a book on learning he does yeah the
art of learning actually
but uh yeah he knows a thing or two
about it but a great guy and anyway
he sat me down one time was like look
man you're doing this wrong you're
missing
what the missing the genius the
brilliance that's right in front of you
and it's something i mean
that i was frustrated with uh with my
inability to grasp
certain things and sometimes uh the
teaching style being different not wrong
just it was
it it was it was tough on me at the time
so you were trying to replicate what
marcelo was saying as opposed to
understanding the
the the the fundamentals from which it
was coming
right i couldn't see i couldn't see
where it was coming from and also
sometimes i'm like
well why can't you explain it in the way
that i would want you to explain it he's
like well why can't i meet
him where he's coming from yeah so
anyway it was a really important
time unless i'm very very frustrating
from honest but it's not um
i'm so thankful for that time and anyway
uh
you know i i guess always first
principles trying to understand the
basics
first starting at the place where you
can't control things uh the the very
basic elements of what you can work with
and then when there's other mentors and
teachers to uh
meet them where they're coming from meet
them to the extent that i can rather
i'm not like again it's like why are you
not talking to me the way i want you to
talk to me
as opposed to hey where are you coming
from back to your point yeah but uh i
know that's not
entirely specific but you know like if
you can focus on that and back to the
whole you can't
teach a man anything marcelo didn't
teach me anything but he taught me
in so doing like and other and other
people like that to uh
you know to find it within and it's like
yeah i guess something else that i've
that i've heard before
is that all learning is self-discovery
but all performance is self-expression
and i always thought that marcelo was a
brilliant master of letting what's
inside out he would he was so consistent
in his performances
and a lot of times i felt like there was
a block there personally particularly at
the end of jiu jitsu when i was very
very results oriented and i wasn't
i think i think my focus was was not
ideal it was definitely not
not in the place that i would like it to
be and whether i would have won more or
lost more hard to say but i know that i
would perform better if i'd have
adjusted that and
anyway uh that recognizing that again
jiu jitsu i think i've said it before
just
studied as a science but expressed as an
art it doesn't matter if you can
articulate what you know how to do what
matters is if you can do what you want
to do it only matters if you're you know
i guess if you're teaching in in a
verbal fashions whether or not you can
articulate it but uh
recognizing the difference between
learning on an intellectual level or a
conceptual level and being able to
to translate that into the physical and
i guess like that's been the thing that
i feel like fortunate over time in my
own academy to be able to kind of fiddle
around and learn on my own
and practice my students and you know
sometimes i struggle to have great
training partners like when i say great
training
i mean other world-class people to spar
to roll with but i've gotten a lot
more honestly than i ever would have
thought out of being able to practice
and learn and fail and try and succeed
on my own without
like my own little sandbox figuring out
how i can take
an idea and then come up with drills and
and
drills to practice it so that i can
actually practice putting it into play
because again
knowing an idea and then not drilling
what's the point i'll never have it it
will never it'll never see the light of
day
you